Colorado hi Kyra welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show what's up yeah so my I've
had it moment my husband I both work for
the government and we were severely
affected by the shutdown or you don't
earlier this year for the 35 days we
were stupid and got a loan to cover
basic expenses and we paid it back
immediately when we got paid but that
was our moment of knowing that we
couldn't keep doing this we have
hundreds and thousands of dollars of
debt and we were just tired of it so
we're looking down the barrel again
because both of us work for the
government of you know it possibly
shutting down around the same time on
December you know just before Christmas
and my question is we've already put
down a thousand dollars in savings and
we're putting down everything we can
towards debt I'm wondering if we should
have something a little more on the side
of savings just in case we are shut down
again and we don't have another paycheck
for over a month or however long we're
shut down for so I guess I missed the
news story I wasn't aware there was a
pending shutdown in December a federal
government shutdown again so basically
what happened is in September they
passed a continuing resolution until
November a monthly curse they passed and
it's due to be renewed December 20th
last year it was December 21st and we
don't know for sure if there's gonna be
a shutdown our hope is that it doesn't
happen again we're just wanting to
prepare well I understand that part I'm
just saying the point I'm making is is
that if there was a political battle
going on that would point towards a
shutdown which is where one party is
using the operation of the federal
government as leverage to get some kind
of legislation through on the other
party that's usually what causes a
shutdown because otherwise I just keep
borrowing
into oblivion and keep paying everybody
right correct which is what the
continuing resolutions are and if there
was a pending shutdown there would be a
lot of news stories about it I
understand but I mean it's fairly common
practice for these continuing
resolutions to just be updated unless
there's some kind of brouhaha in the air
and I haven't heard of one and so I'm
thinking the probability of a shutdown
this Christmas season is considerably
different than last Christmas season
would you agree with that yeah
okay so now I'm the number of times the
federal government has shut down and not
paid you guys on time is so few you have
a fresh wound I understand that we just
started that first of all and we just
don't want to do anything that would put
us back in I don't want you to either
and if you know if the news heats up and
you feel like there's a right now I
would say it's a you know I'm just
sticking a wet finger in the air I
really don't know what I'm talking about
but I'm gauging the amount of news
stories out there on this which are
almost zero okay and so based on that
I'm gonna say there's less than a five
percent chance of a shutdown that the
continuing resolution is probably just
going to sail right through if that
changes and you start seeing news
stories everywhere and your instead of a
ninety five five ratio on percentage
chance of shutdown you end up with going
hey this is 50/50 then I would just stop
my baby step two and build up cash until
the storm blows over but no I do not
change the baby steps because you're in
a volatile job situation I stop working
the baby steps until you get past a
volatile job situation and so like if
you call if someone calls me up
similarly khara and says hey I think I'm
gonna get laid off at work I always try
to figure out what that means does that
mean that there's a 50/50 chance because
they've laid off a bunch of other people
all around you every desk around you is
empty there's a 90% chance you're gonna
get laid off
if so then stop your baby steps and
build up cash but I just have a vague
worry because three years ago some other
people got laid off
no you don't stop it then that's just a
vague worry that's the difference in a
probability of something happening and
worrying but again I appreciate you got
a fresh wound from last year and I
appreciate you don't want take a step
back and all of that but if you really
think there's a 50/50 chance of the
government shutting down on the 20th
based on the information you have that I
don't then you would stop your baby
steps and pile up cash but if there's a
5% chance no you rock on there's a 5%
chance anybody gets laid off on any day
you know that's just life and so you
just keep working through all of that
hey thanks for the call we appreciate
you joining us and I'm glad you're
making progress
wait go